so what formed your political viewpoint
because obviously taking the position as
a black person in america
that racism is not the key factor in
american life or even a key factor in
american life it's pretty controversial
position
where did you get that from because it's
a pretty rare position i got my dad my
father
my father didn't get along um my father
and i had a huge fight when i was 15
years old and we didn't speak for 10
years
and when i say didn't speak ben i mean
did not speak not like
hi dad and that's it i didn't say a word
to him
and i graduated from high school and i
was able to then go to college on the
east coast and law school in the midwest
so basically i avoided my dad for almost
10 years
now my mom my dad just were still
married in the house so when i would
come home
for vacation for summers i would just
make sure i'm not around when he's not
around
and that was pretty easy because my dad
worked long hours he had a cafe
so now i'm fast forward i'm 25 years old
i've now graduated from law school i
have this big
job with a big law firm making a
boatload of money i'm 25 years old and i
should be living large
but ben i can't sleep and i know it has
something to do with my dad
not that i ever thought we'd be buddies
but i called my secretary and i said
cancel all my appointments i'm flying to
la i'll be back in a couple of days
i didn't tell my parents i was coming
because i didn't want my father to
prepare for this
summit so i get to the uh airport drive
get a cab
to the to the restaurant i got in at 1
30 we closed at 2 30.
and i came there with these two big bags
my dad hadn't talked to me in 10 years
he sees me he's
of course surprised he said should i put
your bags in the back where i said no
dad i'm only going to be here for five
or ten minutes i want to tell you
something
he said okay wait till we close i sat
there for an hour
and i said to myself larry don't tee off
on the son of a
just give him the highlights don't don't
just wail into them and so my dad sat
down and i wailed into him
for almost 20 minutes you see how i can
go and i talked for 20 minutes about
every spanking every whipping everything
he ever said to me everything he'd ever
done to me that pissed me off
and i gave him everything and i was
exhausted i'd run out of ammo my dad
goes
is that it you didn't speak to me for 10
years because of that
and i went yeah and my father said let
me tell you about my father and then for
the first time i saw my father cry
i did not think the man had the ability
to summon tears i think he could do that
i knew my father was an only child i
knew we had no relatives because
on his side because we never got any
gifts for christmas aside from that i
knew nothing about my father i met his
mother once when i went to the south
but i knew nothing about my dad and
didn't care i didn't like him my brother
didn't like him either so it wasn't like
i was curious about him so he said let
me tell you about my father
when we're sitting in these two stools
in my dad's cafe he said your last name
elder i said yeah he said that's not the
name of my father
i said what what is your father's name
he said i have no idea
you never met your father no who's elder
he was in my life the longest my mother
had a series of boyfriends each one more
irresponsible than the other one
elder was a drunk uh seldom worked and
when he did he'd take home the money
give it to my mother so that she would
keep it so he wouldn't drink it away and
then come wednesday or thursday he'd
want it if she didn't give it to him he
kicked the crap out of her
if ever i tried to do anything he could
crap out of me
and he was in my life my dad said the
longest how long was the longest he said
four years
i said what after that after that series
of boyfriends i'm now 13 years old my
dad said i came home
from school eighth grade and i was
making too much noise for my mom's then
boyfriend
my mom sided with the boyfriend when he
and i were fighting
and she threw me out of the house age 13
never
to return athens georgia
jim crow south at the beginning of the
great depression i defy you to find
somebody with a hand dealt like that
my father goes down the road ben he
picks up trash that's anything he can do
ultimately he becomes a pullman porter
for the trains they were the largest
private employer of blacks in those days
and so he was able to travel all around
the country which was eye-opening for a
little black boy from the south and he
came to california one time on a run
and it was sunny and people seemed to be
less racist he could walk into a
restaurant and get
served and my dad said to my mom maybe
someday i'll relocate
to l.a pearl harbor my dad joined the
marines
he was the first black marines they were
called the monford point marines people
don't know the know about them but they
were every bit as influential as worthy
tuskegee airmen everybody knows about
there were 20 000 modford point marines
from 1942 to 1940
uh 49 and congress gave them a
professional gold medal a few
a few years ago my dad got his
posthumously
anyway he um was stationed in guam
became a staff sergeant was charging in
charge of the cooking facilities he can
cook anything he could look at a cake
and tell you what was in it
so he goes to chattanooga where he met
married my mom
and he knocks on doors all these
restaurants to get a job as a cook
and they told him we don't hire to his
face he goes to an unemployment office
lady says you went to the wrong door he
goes to the hall he sees colored only
goes through that door to the very same
lady who sent him out he came home to my
mom and said this is bs i'm going to l.a
i'm going to get me a job as a cook and
i'll send for you
comes out to l.a walks around for two or
three days i'm sorry you have no
references
and my dad of course told them that he
was a world war ii vet he cooked for the
service
i'm sorry you have no references my dad
even offered to work for free
just give me a written reference they
wouldn't even do that they treated him
the same way in l.a as they did in
chattanooga they were just a little more
polite about it
he went to an unemployment office one
door sat there in a chair for a day and
a half lady calls him up
i have a job don't know if you're going
to want it my dad says i'm sure i'm
going to want it what is it
and she says cleaning toilets with a
company called nabisco brand bread
my dad did that for 10 years took a
second job cleaning toilets at another
bread company called barber and bread
cooked for a family in pacific palisades
on the weekends and went to night school
two or three nights a week to get his
ged
the man never slept ben an hour here two
hours here you do that
week after week month after month year
after year and you come home with a with
a household full of three rambunctious
boys
and see what kind of mood you're in the
man was tired
and so we talked for eight hours
i asked him everything i could ask him
he asked me about my life the man got
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
and i got smaller and smaller and
smaller
by the end of the hour eight hours i'm
crying and i said dad i am
so sorry and he said larry don't be
just follow the advice i've always given
you and your brothers hard
work wins you get out of life what you
put into it
larry you cannot control the outcome but
damn it you are 100 in control of the
effort
and before you moan and whine about what
somebody did to you go to the nearest
mirror look at it
and say to yourself what could i have
done to change the outcome and finally
he said this
no matter how good you are how hard you
work how moral you are sooner or later
bad things are going to happen to you
how you deal with those bad things will
tell your mom and me whether or not we
raised a man
so i wrote a book about it called dear
father dear son the reason for the title
is because after this eight hour
conversation i fly back to cleveland my
father
writes me a letter he never wrote me a
letter in his life and it said dear son
i wrote him back and i said dear father
i never called him father before and so
then we began this relationship
that lasted 35 years and arguably even
closer than my mom
and i were my mom and i were very very
close so i was able to
uh to salvage my relationship with my
father and have 35 really good years
and the book is called dear father dear
son two lives eight hours and it's on
paperback also called um
a lot like me the reason we changed the
title is because people thought it was a
collection of letters
and the publisher realized that that
turned off people it's really a
it's a novel it reads almost like a
novel but it's a book of
memoirs well it's an amazing story and
it does lead to the question which is
i mean your dad obviously an enormously
tough individual
just from the story and and you're a
tough guy too in the sense that you've
taken an enormous number of slings and
arrows over the years
to take this position why do you think
it is that so few folks
in my not just the black community the
hispanic community a lot of various
minority communities
tend to not move along those lines tend
to tend to not
suggest that the first indicator of
success is individual decision making
but the first thing that we have to
overcome as a society's institutional
racism or
some sort of miasma of discrimination
that is preventing people from achieving
their goals
it's a complicated question but but it
starts with the family and i know it
sounds counter
counterintuitive because my father had
no family but if you don't have a a
family role model inside the house
father inside the house you're in
trouble
out of the gate and 70 of black kids
today
are born to unwed mothers and
the number was 25 in 1965 and what we've
done with our welfare state and the
so-called war on poverty which lyndon
johnson launched
is to incentivize women to marry the
government and allow men to abandon
their financial and more responsibility
and the the the black kind of victimhood
mentality
is a phenomenon of the civil rights
movement going from demanding equal
rights to demanding equal results and
that's what we have right now people are
demanding equal results
results have to be earned uh rights come
from god uh and so
people like jesse jackson and the
congressional black caucus and the naacp
and this whole cabal
of organizations telling black people
that they're victims is a huge part of
the problem
how do you think that conservatives
should go about speaking to black folks
obviously because
that's been a serious issue every time
somebody tries to engage with the black
community
uh they're they're folks on the left who
particularly start calling them those
people racist right suggesting that
they're pandering
and that's because nobody really wants
to tell the truth uh cory booker just
the other day said he wanted to have an
honest dialogue about race no you don't
if you have an honest dialogue about
race you don't want to hear it
uh to me the most dangerous race hustler
in america is not sharpton
he's bad not jackson he's bad not some
of the yahoos you see on cable
television they're all bad
but it's eric holder because people
listen to eric holder
he's sophisticated he's got degrees from
from columbia undergraduate
and uh and law school works for a very
prestigious law firm
was a respected to the left uh a.g
he says the most outrageous things
and gets away with it for example he
gave a speech in which he talked about
pernicious racism
this is around the time that donald
sterling lost his team remember he was
taped by his girlfriend and made some
disparaging comments about blacks and
ended up losing his team
and eric holder said that kind of
blatant racism that kind of blatant
bigotry we got that
that's not the problem the problem is
the pernicious racism
and he gave three examples none of which
hold up the first example was the push
for voter id
polls show that about 80 percent of
whites want voter id and about 70 of
hispanics do
about the same number of blacks do and
there was a study recently by
by researchers from yale from stanford
and from penn and they looked at the
research paper that reported the show
that voter id suppressed
black and brown votes and they trashed
the methodology these
other researchers used and said there's
no evidence whatsoever that these voter
id laws suppress black turnout
furthermore 2008 when obama got elected
for the first time in history despite
all these alleged voter suppression
efforts
the percentage of eligible black voters
who voted exceeded the percentage of
eligible white voters who voted
so it's nonsense the second one he gave
is that black kids are expelled
at disproportionately high rates
compared to their percentage
of that given school and um and it's
true
they are jesse jackson some years ago
sued the decatur school board which
was was all white because they kicked
out a bunch of black kids who were
fighting after a football game
turns out the kids had missed
collectively like three four hundred
days of school
anyway they kicked him out in comes
jesse jackson
accuses the school board of racism files
a lawsuit school board defended itself
by pointing out
that at other school districts where the
school boards are primarily people of
color
black boys are still disproportionately
kicked out and they mentioned oakland
which was primarily
a school board members of people of
color uh
san francisco also the majority of the
school board members were people of
color
and yet the black boys were kicked out
far more compared to other people
when you look at their position in that
given school so it's just
a lie and the lawsuit was thrown out the
third thing that eric holder said
is that black criminal defendants who
commit the same crime will get a longer
sentence than white criminal defendants
and that's true
but the u.s sensing commission says the
reason for that is that judges taken
consideration on the time of sentencing
your criminal history
and other factors for example whether or
not you have a working history
whether or not you show remorse all
those factors so even the u.s sensing
commission to which eric holder referred
said you can't conclude one way or the
other whether or not bias is
is operating here there could be all
sorts of factors to explain this so
that's the best you can do and this is
the front runner guy
uh who's articulating the the racism in
america
uh all you could do is come up with
voter id and this expulsion stuff
uh and the sentencing stuff he didn't
even say uh they were dispersingly
arrested
didn't even didn't even come there come
near and near saying that
so uh it's a lie and he
said all these things and people sat
there and they politely listened to it
and it seemed respectable and nobody
challenged it except for me i wrote an
article about each one
i wrote one about the expulsion rates i
wrote one about voter id
and i wrote one about sentencing did you
know that every like on this video
creates one
additional glorious leftist here don't
ask me why that's called science
to take advantage of this amazing
opportunity just hit the like button